la loi de programmation militaire pour
les années 2010 9 à 2025
adopté en 2018 à une très large majorité
a traduit l'engagement pris par le
président de la république devant la
nation en 2010 est de fixer une nouvelle
ambition pour notre défense nationale et
de restaurer les moyens qui lui sont
affectés
vous me permettrez d'emblée de saluer
devant la haute assemblée le travail de
la ministre des armées madame florence
parly qui a élaboré puis appliquer cette
loi avec la rigueur et la détermination
qu'on lui connaît et vous me permettrez
d'associer à ces remerciements
geneviève darrieussecq placé sous son
autorité
ce texte a fait l'objet d'un important
travail avec le parlement dans sa
préparation comme dans le suivi de son
exécution et je voudrais saluer tout
particulièrement les sénateurs de la
commission des affaires étrangères de la
défense et des forces armées monsieur le
président et qui ont notamment en 2017
et 2018 activement contribué le texte
prévoyait que la lpm fasse l'objet d'une
actualisation de fixer de façon à fixer
pardon au delà de 2023
la trajectoire des ressources qui devait
permettre d'atteindre l'objectif fixé
par le président de la république
notamment celui de porter le budget des
armées à 2% du pib à l'horizon de 2025
il se trouve que la crise sanitaire ou
plus exactement les conséquences
économiques et financières de cette
crise ont significativement bouleversé
le contexte dans lequel cette
actualisation était prévu
d'une part à raison de la récession
il se trouve que l'objectif de 2% du pib
se trouvent déjà tu
mais surtout et d'autre part la longueur
de la crise sanitaire
hélas toujours pas complètement terminé
ses conséquences économiques dans un
contexte qui reste incertain et que
personne ne pouvait anticiper au moment
de la préparation et du vote de la loi
ont changé les conditions de cette
actualisation et donc les perspectives
pour 2024 et 2025 puisque tel est le
sujet essentiel c'est pourquoi j'ai
décidé je l assume de ne pas soumettre à
ce moment précis au parlement de textes
d'actualisation de la loi de
programmation militaire
cette actualisation devra bien sûr
intervenir dès que l'horizon économique
et financier sera clarifiée en
contrepartie j'ai voulu que l'effort
entrepris pour notre défense soit
solennellement débattu et je l'espère
confirmée par la représentation
nationale que le parlement puisse
délibérer de la mise en oeuvre de la
programmation militaire et des
inflexions éventuelle à lui donner c'est
la raison pour laquelle j'ai invoqué une
nouvelle fois monsieur le président
l'article 50-1 de la constitution mais
je crois pour la première fois pour un
premier ministre s'agissant d'un sujet
intéressant notre défense nationale
cette loi de programmation militaire
porte vous le savez mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs une ambition
claire permettre à la france de
retrouver un modèle d'armée complet et
équilibré à la hauteur
des enjeux stratégiques d'aujourd'hui et
de demain cette ambition est d'autant
plus indispensable que nous sommes
désormais confrontés à un dérèglement du
monde pour reprendre les mots utilisés
par le chef de l'état à la menace
toujours présente du terrorisme à cette
menace qui relaie son obscurantisme par
les réseaux de communication les plus
modernes tout en faisant appel à la
technologie pour exploiter ou tenter
d'exploiter les failles de nos systèmes
de sécurité à l'émiettement de la
violence sans frein qu'elle provoque
s'est ajoutée la montée des appétits de
certains pays en quête de puissance pour
construire un modèle complet et
équilibré capable de faire face à ces
menaces d'aujourd'hui comme à celle de
demain le présent la république a voulu
donner l'impulsion nécessaire à une
transformation profonde de nos armées
c'est ce qu'a traduit la loi de
programmation militaire
le premier objectif le plus urgent était
d'abord de réparer les armées dans les
matériels étaient en mauvais état la
ténacité le professionnalisme de nos
soldats marins et aviateurs dont
l'engagement est souvent allé bien
au-delà de ce que prévoyaient les
contrats opérationnels et auxquels je
veux une nouvelle fois devant vous
rendre hommage à vais vous le savez de
plus en plus de difficultés à pallier la
dégradation de leurs conditions
d'intervention réparer donc pour rendre
à nos armes et les moyens de remplir
durablement les missions qui sont les
leurs préparée mais aussi second
objectif préparer l'avenir c'est-à-dire
anticipé moderniser innover de façon à
permettre à nos forces de disposer du
matériel le plus performant et en nombre
suffisant qui soit adaptée aux menaces
nouvelles 7 avec la faire
volonté de réussir cette double
opération de régénération et de
modernisation que la lpm a consacré une
hausse historique du budget militaire
la force de nos armées est donc en
réalité notre capacité à rester maître
de notre destin
aux côtés de nos voisins européens et de
nos alliés départ un effet de notre
capacité à nous inscrire dans le temps
long de l'histoire
à cet effet il convenait d'abord d'avoir
des budgets en conformité avec nos
besoins dans les dix années précédant le
vote de la lpm de 2018
les crédits votés en loi de finances
initiale pour la mission défense était
quasi systématiquement inférieurs à ceux
prévus
cet écart pouvant aller jusqu'à 2,3
milliards d'euros sur une année donnée
durant cette période et le sénat du
reste là souvent relevé ce ne sont pas
moins de 3 8 milliards d'euros qui ont
fait l'objet d'annulation ou de
régulation
pas moins de soixante mille postes qui
ont été supprimés dans nos armées si
bien que notre effort de défense est
passé progressivement de 2,1 pour cent
du pib à 1,78 % en 2017
c'est à cette situation qu'il convenait
de mettre fin et ensemble nous l'avons
fait le budget annuel a été portée par
la volonté du pouvoir exécutif et par
votre vote
à près de 40 milliards d'euros seuil
symbolique qui devrait être dépassé avec
le plf pour 2022 contre environ 30
milliards en moyenne annuelle sur la
période précédente
très concrètement avec l'augmentation de
1,8 milliard d'euros en 2018
ce sont des hausses le budget de 1,7
milliard d'euros qui ont été confirmés
chaque année depuis lors au total depuis
le début du quinquennat le budget annuel
des armées aura augmenté de plus de 25%
sur cette même période en cumul les
ressources supplémentaires apportés par
ces autres représentent 27 milliards
d'euros soit plus de deux années de
budget d'équipement une accélération
sans précédent de l'investissement de
lausanne et plus récemment
mesdames et messieurs sénateurs les
attire votre attention sur le choix
politiques et budgétaires que nous avons
fait de maintenir cette dynamique en
2020 et 2021 alors même que la crise
sanitaire nous a par ailleurs conduit à
puiser très significativement dans nos
finances publiques
je le dis car certains pays se sont
servis de leurs dépenses militaires
comme variable d'ajustement
tel ne fut pas le cas de la france aussi
je peux affirmer devant vous que les
ressources les objectifs de la
programmation sont strictement
respectées et c'est une réalité que vous
me permettrez de qualifiée d' historique
puisqu'il s'agit de la première elle pm
ou annuellement les volumes de crédits
exécutés sont conformes à ce qui avait
été autorisé par la représentation
nationale et ce dès 2018
ce ne fut le car vous le savez toutes et
tous exceptionnellement pour les lois de
programmation antérieur et je vous le
dis c'est dans ce même esprit que nous
préparons la loi de finances pour 2022
il ne faut pas dans ces conditions
s'étonner mesdames et messieurs
sénateurs que la mise en oeuvre de la
loi de programmation militaire et
produit les résultats significatifs les
premières à mesure vous y avait
d'ailleurs contribué ont été à hauteur
d'homme selon l'expression consacrée
elles ont permis d'agir sur le quotidien
de celles et ceux qui choisissent le
métier des armes
ces mesures très concrètes ont en effet
viser à améliorer leurs conditions de
vie d'entraînement et de combat et à cet
effet nous avons investi de manière
inédite dans les infrastructures
notamment en termes de casernement dans
l'intention portée aux familles dans le
logement mais aussi dans
l'accompagnement des carrières notamment
à travers la mise en place d'une
nouvelle politique de rémunération plus
moderne et plus juste
parallèlement nous avons accéléré la
modernisation de nos équipements
c'est le cas notamment de notre
dissuasion nucléaire dont le
renouvellement des composante aérienne
et sous marine est désormais engagée je
fais référence aussi bien sûr nouveau
véhicule blindé conçu dans le cadre du
programme scorpion qui renforce
considérablement la puissance de feu la
protection de notre armée de terre je
pense encore notre marina qui les
nouveaux sous marins de type suffren des
fremm frégates de défense et
d'intervention et demain le futur
porte-avions vont permettre de faire
face aux nouveaux défis
porté par les perturbateurs de l'ordre
international sur mer je pense enfin à
notre armée de l'air que sa flotte
d'avions de chasse et de drones armés va
mettre au meilleur niveau mondial et qui
a enfin pu renouveler son parc d'avions
de transport et de ravitailleurs
certains ont pu s'inquiéter ici même des
retards qu'ils ont cru observée dans les
livraisons de tel ou tel type
d'équipement madame la ministre des
armées pourra vous donner toutes les
explications nécessaires notamment sur
les aléas qui en sont la cause
et qu'ils sont mais finalement la
contrepartie d'une loi de programmation
ambitieuse laquelle compte que vous le
savez des centaines de programmes
différents
c'est vrai dans l'intérieur du cadre
global les uns prennent de la vence
d'autres du retard ces variations sont
finalement le reflet d'une gestion
dynamique et réactive de la
programmation l'essentiel c'est que l'on
force dispose des équipements dont elles
ont besoin au bon moment os engagés en
opération
par ailleurs et c'est un élément
essentiel de notre politique de défense
la modernisation de nos forces se doit
être valorisée par une autonomie
stratégique renforcée est accompagné
d'un effort inédit en matière de
renseignement
c'est évidemment dans ce secteur que la
lutte contre le terrorisme exige un
investissement majeur et nous l'avons
consenti entre 2019 et 2023
permettez-moi d'anticiper le montant
annuel moyen du budget de renseignements
sera de 400 millions d'euros environ
contre 260 millions d'euros en moyenne
sur la période 2014 2018
nos services de renseignement verront
ainsi leurs effectifs augmenter et 25 %
des créations de la loi leur seront
consacrés de nouvelles capacités seront
développés en particulier pour
intercepter les communications des
groupes terroristes
le fonctionnement de nos services sera
modernisée et la construction d'un
nouveau siège pour la dgse qui vient
d'être tout récemment confirmée par le
président de la république anh est une
illustration emblématique
il en va de même s'agissant du domaine
cyber pour lequel la loi de
programmation prévoit 1,6 milliard
d'euros afin de consolider l'autonomie
stratégique de la france
l'accroissement du nombre de cyber
combattants traduit notre volonté
d'investir ce nouvel espace de conflit
que tu as lité et nous disons un
objectif de plus de 4000 au terme de la
période couverte par la loi le ministère
dispose d'ores et déjà de 3000 cyber
combattants et un poste un paul pardon
cyber des armées sera créé afin de
concentrer les expertises mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs ce nouvel élan
impulsé à notre défense va évidemment de
pair avec la volonté de la france
d'amplifier la relance de l'europe de la
défense
l'union européenne a ainsi fait du fonds
européen de défense une réalité tangible
avec une milliards d'euros courants
d'investissement pour son premier budget
l'union investit désormais directement
dans les capacités militaires ce qui
constitue une avancée majeure dans sa
prise en compte des enjeux de défense il
en est de même de la facilité européenne
de paix qui soutenue par la france est
approuvée par le conseil européen le 22
mars dernier pour un montant de 5
milliards d'euros témoigne de
l'engagement collectif des pays de
l'union à s'engager pour la paix et la
stabilité internationale notre pays vous
le savez du rsa jouer un rôle moteur
pour que des projets ambitieux soit
lancé dans le cadre de la coopération
structurée permanente qui a donné lieu à
l'avalisation de 46 projets auxquels
participent 25 pays
avec nos partenaires européens nous
avons aussi engagé des programmes
d'équipement stratégique
je pense en particulier au système de
combat aérien du futur qui associe comme
vous le savez la france l'allemagne et
l'espagne
ce programme ambitieux qui associera
avions de chasse et et dronne
d'accompagnement donnera notre pays et
plus largement en europe un avantage
stratégique pour la maîtrise du ciel et
les missions dans la troisième dimension
dans le champ opérationnel l'initiative
européenne intervention constitue un
cadre souple pour réunir les nations qui
veulent agir ensemble et il est en train
de s'imposer comme une instance reconnue
d'interopérabilité stratégique pour
revenir en france
je veux insister devant vous sur les
impacts de la loi de programmation
militaire en termes de relance
d'industrie et d'emplois sur la première
partie de cette loi 2019 et 2023 cinq
ans ce sont pas moins de 110 milliards
d'euros qui auront été injectés dans
l'économie pour les équipements les
infrastructures ainsi que le maintien en
conditions opérationnelles venant ainsi
soutenir puissamment notre économie sur
les exercices 2021 et 2022 correspondent
à la période du plan de relance se 140
milliards d'euros qui vont être investis
dans nos entreprises et dans nos
territoires notamment à travers le plan
de soutien aéronautique
il faut ajouter à ces montants ceux de
nos exportations d'armements grâce
auquel entre 2018 et 2020 plus de 21
milliards d'euros de commandes vont
contribuer au dynamisme de nos régions
comment ne pas insister devant vous sur
les succès du rafale à l'export
notamment avec les ventes récentes à la
grèce à l'egypte et à la croatie qui
elle aussi vous le savez
irrigue tout le tissu industriel de
l'aéronautique de défense et ces
investissements sont ciblés pour que
l'efficacité économique accompagnent
leurs pertinences opérationnel je
voudrais mesdames et messieurs les
parlementaires saluer ici les efforts
menés par la délégation générale pour
l'armement pour soutenir l'écosystème
des industries de défense si important
pour notre souveraineté industrielle
avec j insiste une attention toute
particulière portée aux petites et
moyennes entreprises
au total les investissements de la lpm
vont contribuer à créer environ 25000
emplois directs supplémentaires d'ici à
2022 et jusqu'à 70 milles à l'horizon
la seule filière de l'industrie de
défense représente de l'ordre de 200
mille emplois de haut niveau répartis
dans toutes les régions
j insiste devant la chambre des
territoires
j'insiste également sur le fait que
notre armée mais vous le savez est le
premier service recruteurs de l'état
elle ouvre chaque année à des dizaines
de milliers de jeunes le chemin de la
compétence de l'épanouissement et de la
méritocratie républicaine
enfin il vous le savez elles demeurent
implanté en de nombreux endroits de
notre territoire national les objectifs
prévus dans la loi de programmation
militaire elle militaires ont donc été
pleinement respectée et je tiens devant
vous a salué l'action sous l'autorité de
la ministre du chef d'état-major des
armées du délégué général pour
l'armement et de la secrétaire général
pour l'administration du ministère des
armées qui ont tous eu un rôle décisif
dans la mise en oeuvre de ce texte et
vous me permettrez dans cette
circonstance d'avoir une mention
spéciale pour le général françois
lecointre
dans les moments ultimes de sa carrière
militaire
[Applaudissements]
l'évolution du contexte stratégique est
venu confirmer la pertinence des
priorités de la loi de programmation
militaire depuis 2018 la prolifération
des armes nucléaires est à nouveau une
inquiétude majeure les actes hostiles se
sont multipliées dans les airs et sur
les mers par exemple méditerranée ou en
mer de chine des puissances régionales
ont pris des positions stratégiques sans
égard pour le droit international
quant à la menace terroriste je l'ait
déjà évoquée elle s'est diversifiée et
développer les dispositions prévues par
la loi de programmation militaire
doivent nous permettre de relever ces
défis
comme vous le savez face à de nouvelles
menaces nous avons d'ores et déjà
procédé à des infections par exemple je
veux il insisté devant le sénat en
renforçant notre action dans le domaine
spatial
la création d'un commandement
interarmées dédié l'effort que nous
faisons pour pouvoir opérer dans
l'espace pour y surveiller nos
adversaires pour protéger nos satellites
s'inscrivent dans cette projection
déterminé vers un avenir qui ne peut se
permettre de dupliquer ce qui existe
déjà aujourd'hui le budget d'équipement
consacrée à l'espace a ainsi été
quasiment doublé depuis 2000 17 les
crises récentes et les leçons que notre
pays a su en tirer ont permis les
ajustements qui doivent permettre
désormais de détecter les menaces et de
nous rendre plus résilient
c'est tout le sens des efforts accrus
prévu en matière de capacités
opérationnelles notamment dans les
domaines le prioritaires que sont les
risques nucléaires radiologiques
biologiques
chimiques mais aussi la santé la lutte
anti drogue ou encore la lutte
informationnel nos forces qui s'adapte
sans cesse aux menaces sont fortement
mobilisés notamment pour lutter contre
le terrorisme dans le cadre d'opérations
extérieures au sahel ou au levant comme
sur le territoire national dans le cadre
de l'opération sentinelle déployés
depuis 2015 et que nous devons toujours
laissé active mais cette menace comme du
reste la situation géopolitique évolué
c'est pourquoi j'insiste une nouvelle
fois devant vous nous conduisons
simultanément l'ajustement de la
programmation militaire et l'adaptation
de nos engagements en fonction du
contexte stratégique ne pas s'adapter en
permanence aux terrains combo
circonstances c'est évidemment prendre
un risque majeur
cette règle aussi ancienne que l'art de
la guerre est toujours d'actualité
c'est cette raison qui explique
l'annoncé par le président de la
république de la transformation de notre
dispositif
oh ça aide le passage d'une logique
d'opérations extérieures à celui d'un
dispositif de coopération accrue avec
les pays du g5 ça elle doit ainsi nous
permettre de mieux faire face encore
défi de cette région
ainsi nous continuerons à lutter contre
les groupes terroristes et
accompagneront nos partenaires du sel
avec la force européenne
ta cuba celle-ci vous le savez tout à
fait inédite pour la première fois des
pays européens s'engagent ensemble mais
de manière autonome dans des actions de
combat
nos partenaires et alliés ont ainsi
compris à quel point la stabilité de
cette région du monde
conditionnait la sécurité du continent
européen
et je voudrais à cette tribune
une nouvelle fois leur rendre un hommage
solennel
cette évolution marque ainsi une étape
significative dans notre engagement au
sahel
et le gouvernement proposera au
parlement un débat spécifique sur ce
sujet je veux rendre hommage à nos
soldats marins et aviateurs engagé en
opération extérieure de façon plus
globale au moment où une attaque au
véhicule suicide vient de blesser si de
nos soldats en même temps que quatre
civils maliens
j'ai mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
avez-vous en cet instant à l'esprit tous
ceux qui ont payé leur engagement au
prix du sang nous leur en serons
éternellement reconnaissants car la
france n'oublie jamais celles et ceux
qui sont tombés pour défendre notre
liberté et notre souveraineté
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
grâce à l'effort historique réalisé sous
l'impulsion du président de la
république
nos armées ont pu être dotée de
ressources à la hauteur de leur mission
est engagé leur construction et leur
modernisation
cet effort évidemment il engage la
nation toute entière
il mobilise jeune eddy est illustré des
ressources financières considérables
cet effort nous vous proposons de le
poursuivre sans relâche de le poursuivre
pour que notre pays puisse assurer sa
défense et faire face aux défis qui
viennent de le poursuivre parce que sa
longue histoire a appris à notre pays de
génération en génération le caractère
redoutable de céder si ce travail je
considère qu'il ne peut être conduit
qu'un accord avec le parlement
je le dis d'ailleurs au moment où je
viens d'apprendre que le bundestag vient
de voter en faveur du scaf auquel je
faisais référence tout à l'heure
c'est dans cet esprit que je me suis
exprimée devant vous cet après midi un
esprit d'union et de concorde car
lorsqu'il s'agit de la souveraineté de
notre pays et de la sécurité de nos
concitoyens
lorsqu'il s'agit de la place de la
france dans le monde je sais pouvoir
compter sur le sens des responsabilités
des sénatrices et des sénateurs aussi la
ministre comme moi même sommes
particulièrement à l'écouté de vos
contributions analyses et propositions
que ce débat pourra permettre de mettre
en exergue à l'issue je vous demanderais
par votre vote de renouveler
l'engagement que nous avons pris en 2018
et de confirmer ainsi notre ambition
collective en matière de défense comme
en matière de moyens concrets et
significativement renforcée que nous
affectons à nos forces armées et à nos
soldats
grâce à cette loi de programmation
militaire c'est une question de sécurité
bien sûr c'est une question de
souveraineté
c'est une question qui fondent
finalement le rayonnement de la france
dans le monde
je vous remercie je voudrais d'abord
commencé ce propos n'ayant à mon tour et
au nom de tous nos collègues une pensée
pour nous forces armées singulièrement
pour nous forces en opex qui paient un
lourd tribut les six blessés que vous
avez évoquées en témoigne sachez bien
que c'est aussi pour eux et c'est
surtout pour eux que le sénat se bat il
ya trois ans dans cet hémicycle madame
la ministre des armées que nous déclare
y est
le gouvernement ne souhaite pas se
soustraire
à une évaluation qui interviendra à un
moment où la majorité et le chef de
l'état seront toujours aux
responsabilités vous assuriez ainsi que
le gouvernement assumerait l'évaluation
de la lpm devant le parlement
et vous le faisiez avec beaucoup de
sincérité force est de constater
néanmoins que cette actualisation
promise devant le sénat est inscrite
dans le texte même de la loi ne s'est
pas franchement concrétiser devant le
parlement
et croyez bien que nous le déplorons est
ce parce que les circonstances ont
changé et bien ou bien sur wii les
circonstances ont changé mais dans un
sens défavorable avec la montée des
menaces
la crise du coc vide et la précision et
la pression toujours plus forte sur nos
finances publiques
et c'est précisément pour cela qu'il
fallait une loi
cette programmation militaire que le
sénat a soutenu à une immense majorité
je vous le rappelle monsieur premier
ministre 3 126 voix pour et 14 contre
avait besoin et a toujours besoin d'une
actualisation est ce que nous contestons
c'est la méthode qui a été employé je
vous le dis très simplement monsieur le
premier ministre
alors que jusqu'à présent à trois
reprises sur trois exercices budgétaires
vous avez je vous en donne acte
respecter l'engagement de la loi de
programmation militaire
cette décision d'ignorer l'application
de l'article 7 de cette loi de décevoir
en quelques mots en quelque sorte la
confiance que nous avons placé dans le
gouvernement pour appliquer ces
dispositifs
et bien cela notre commission ne l'a pas
vraiment comprises on ne trouvera pas
plus de cohérence à cette décision en se
référant aux orientations données par le
président de la république
j'étais comme la ministre à brest à ses
voeux aux forces armées lorsqu'il a
salué je cite le rôle essentiel de nos
parlementaires qui chaque année
il ya la bonne exécution protégeant de
la loi protégeant nos propres
engagements et notre capacité à
affronter les défis de demain est du
reste à chaque exercice budgétaire
le sénat a voté le budget des armées
c'est bien cela l'objectif du sénat
faire respecter les engagements pris et
notre capacité à faire face aux menaces
de demain
alors puisque le gouvernement nous a
refusé cette loi d'actualisation promise
nous avons donc dû mener notre propre
travail d' analyse du périmètre
d'actualisation trois ans après le vote
de la loi
ce travail de six mois que j'ai menées
au nom de la commission avec jean marc
todeschini a été réalisée avec le
soutien déterminé de nos vies rapporteur
budgétaire pour avis et je veux ici
solennellement les remercier car ils ont
travaillé dans des conditions difficiles
se heurtant souvent un refus de
communiquer un certain nombre
d'informations
or ce travail collectif est important et
il aboutit à des conclusions
particulièrement importante sur la forme
les enjeux de cette actualisation ne
permettent pas à l'évidence de traiter
l'actualisation au cours d'un débat de
deux heures pas plus que par des
auditions en commission
sur le fond la loi d'actualisation de la
lpm ce sont des chiffres ce sont des
tableaux c'est la possibilité de creuser
certains sujets d'établir des priorités
d'identifier les retards les
redéploiements les surcoûts et par
conséquent les économies à réaliser en
fonction de ses priorités
et donc pourquoi pas d'amender le projet
du gouvernement peut nous proposer rien
de tout cela je vous écoutait avec
attention dresser le bilan certes
élogieux mais regardons l'avenir
vous ne proposez rien de tout cela alors
que c'est la norme démocratique dans
tous les parlements
est ce que vous aviez promis au
parlement à nos armées et aux français
alors de quoi parlons nous ou plutôt de
quoi aurions nous dû parler le
gouvernement a affirmé que la loi ne se
justifiait pas car finalement
l'actualisation était modeste portant
sur 1 milliard d'euros sur l'ensemble de
la lpm
pourtant bien des éléments nouveaux sont
survenus ces trois dernières années
irruption de nouvelles menaces la
cyberdéfense l'espace la nécessité
d'accroître notre capacité en matière de
renseignement des retards de la part des
industriels les conséquences de la va
vendre des rafale prélevés sur nos
propres forces
le coût de la propulsion nucléaire du
futur porte-avions de nouvelle
génération le coût des études
la commande non prévue d'une frégate de
défense et d'interventions
supplémentaires et bien sûr et bien sûr
l'impact de l'aco vide
c'est pourquoi de notre point de vue la
réalité tout autre
alors que nous n'en sommes même pas à la
moitié de la lpm nous avons chiffré le
périmètre d'actualisation à 8 milliards
6,2 euros
ces huit fois plus que ce que ce qui
avait été annoncé
et croyez moi il ne s'agit pas d'un
travail de petits comptables comme vos
amis de l'assemblée se sont permis de le
qualifier hier et encore nous avons fait
le choix de faire une estimation très
prudente
[Applaudissements]
c'était pas très aimable
c'était pas très aimable pour notre
assemblée mais enfin
et encore nous avons fait le choix d'une
estimation très prudente
il faudrait y ajouter les chiffres que
le ministère des armées ne nous a pas
communiqué sur les sommes qui seront
nécessaires d'ici 2025 pour la
préparation opérationnelle et pour
l'adaptation à la haute intensité
la conséquence c'est la révision à la
baisse de nombreux programmes et c'est
de cela mais sur le premier ministre
qu'il fallait nous parler de la baisse
du sis de la baisse du système de lutte
antimines du futur le bâtiment
hydrographique qui ne va pas être livrés
sur 7
lp/m alors que le bâtiment date de 1981
le programme scorpion dont
l'accélération était un des éléments mis
en valeur pour cet lp m il prend lui
aussi du retard
27 griffon de moins que prévu en 2025 et
qu'en sera-t-il des jaguars et quid de
la modernisation du char leclerc dont la
pérennité dans nos forces est
aujourd'hui en question
quant à la régénération des véhicules
blindés légers sur lequel notre
commission ne cesse de
vous alertez ce sont 123 véhicule qui
manqueront en 2025
il ya aussi les forces spéciales dans le
contexte que nous connaissons au sahel
comment expliquer 51 véhicules légers
des forces spéciales en moins c'est vrai
que c'est un travail de comptable et le
nombre de poids lourds qui va être
réduit à moitié alors qu'il est si
important et puis il ya ce sujet majeur
des rafales contrairement à ce que le
gouvernement a affirmé la cible des 129
rafale en 2025 ne sera pas atteinte
puisque elle est revue à 117 appareils
en raison du prélèvement de 12 appareils
du contrat croate
alors monsieur le premier ministre
reprenons peut-être ce que vous avez dit
à l'assemblée nationale hier
confirmez-vous devant le sénat que ces
douze appareils seront bien remplacer et
quand le seront ils au delà de ces
grands programmes
au-delà de ces grands programmes
d'autres sujets méritait tout autant un
examen attentif par le parlement
c'est le cas du service de santé des
armées nous avions alerté depuis
longtemps sur la centaine de médecins
qui manquait à ce service
malheureusement nos travaux ont révélé
une aggravation de la situation puisque
l'on passe d'un déficit de 97 postes à
2002 en 2020 à 136 en 2021
en pleine crise du coc vide enfin
l'annoncé de la fin de l'opération
barkan sans plus de précisions à ce jour
est évidemment un élément majeur de
toute programmation militaire
là encore nous avons appris cela par
voie de presse et lorsque le sénat a
organisé un débat sur barkan en février
dernier la fin de l'opération n'a jamais
été évoqué comme une option possible par
le gouvernement nous rappelons que le
surcoût des opex a déjà coûté 600
millions d'euros au budget de la défense
pour les seules années 2019 et 2020 or
vous vous en souvenez le sénat avait
fait voter dans la lpm c'est un texte de
loi le principe d'une prise en charge
interministériel de ce coup vous avez
ignoré cette disposition nous le
regrettons qu'elle sera dure est la
conséquence de cette décision de barkan
sur les crédits des armées est-ce qu'il
faut espérer un
- faut-il redouter à court terme un
surcoût lié au démantèlement de
certaines installations
vous venez d'annoncer un débat il
intervient bien tard mais je le prends
aussi comme un signe d'espérance
en fait on voit bien que par l'ampleur
des sommes en jeu et par la gravité des
sujets une oie d'actualisation était
indispensable
alors monsieur le premier ministre
pourquoi y avez vous renoncé
vous nous répondez on ne connaît pas le
pib à l'horizon 2025
permettez moi de vous le dire c'est à la
fois trompeur est inquiétant c'est
trompeur car le fond du sujet vous le
savez bien ce n'est pas un pourcentage
de pipe
le pub actuellement il varie de manière
très sensible
c'est le montant des crédits nécessaires
pour faire besoin pour faire face aux
besoins de cette ambition 2030 du
président de la république
ce niveau est connue nous l'avons
discuter en 2018 c'est une enveloppe de
295 milliards d'euros sur sept ans c'est
trompeur c'est aussi inquiétant en
refusant de confirmer la trajectoire
financière vous fait planer quelque part
le doute sur la programmation
si cette enveloppe n'est pas tenue c'est
l'ensemble de la lpm qui risque d'être
fragilisée
nous l'avons connu dans d'autres lp/m
tous ensemble monsieur le premier
ministre
les sénatrices et les sénateurs qui sont
devant vous sont tous des élus de
terrain
nous savons bien quelle est la situation
de nos finances publiques et de notre
économie au sortir de la crise du coc
vide
oui cet objectif de 295 milliards est
difficile à tenir mais il est
indispensable car il en va de la
sécurité des français
or pour que nos compatriotes accepte de
fournir cet effort
il faut qu'ils aient conscience des
enjeux et des choix à faire
cette validation des choix ne peut
prendre une forme en démocratie le vote
de la loi par le parlement
alors monsieur le premier ministre
parlant de la suite vous nous proposez
vous l'avez fait hier une nouvelle
méthode
il est évident en effet que ce débat ne
peut servir d'actualisation de la lpm en
revanche peut-être est-il le début d'un
travail qui aurait pu avoir lieu entre
le gouvernement et le parlement
pour conclure monsieur le premier
ministre ou le comprenez nous sommes
capables de tout entendre nous sommes
capables de tout comprendre
c'est le non respect par le gouvernement
de l'article 7 de la lpm qui a tout
déclenché votre déclaration
d'aujourd'hui sera jugée à l'épreuve des
faits il revient bien sûr à chaque
groupe de s'exprimer aujourd'hui
mais écoutons bien ceci le sénat est une
institution de la république dont la
mission quoi qu'il en coûte
quoi qu'il en coûte et de contrôler
l'action du gouvernement sur la défense
et les forces armées
le soutien du sénat ne vous a jamais
manqué alors à votre tour
donnez nous des preuves de votre respect
pour le sénat nous attendions cette
année 2021 comme le prévoyait l'article
7 de la lpm voter en 2018 un projet de
loi d'actualisation tout le justifiait
l'engagement législative d'abord mais
aussi les évolutions du contexte
géostratégique et le bouleversement des
priorités qu'impose la crise pandémique
pour la sécurité humaine mondiale
il n'aura il n'y aura rien de tout cela
nous attendions portant ce débat sur
tous les bons ceux qui ont voté la loi
de programmation militaire comme ceux
qui comme les nôtres l'avait refusée
vous avez décidé d'expédier cette
discussion est essentielle en deux
heures on nous demandons un quitus pour
la suite de la mise en oeuvre de la
trajectoire programmé en clair vous
réduisez une fois encore le rôle du
parlement dans l'élaboration de choix
nationaux fondamentaux escamoter le
parlement sur des sujets d'une telle
importance est grave
d'autant que le contrôle parlementaire
sur nos stratégies de défense est déjà
largement limité par les prérogatives
exorbitantes du chef de l'état
engagement d eau que des opérations
militaires extérieures autorisation des
exportations d'armes dissuasion
nucléaire les domaines réservés
réduisent déjà beaucoup le rôle du
parlement alors que la france y joue sa
sécurité
un débat d'actualisation oreilles
ouverts en nécessaire espace
démocratique bien plus efficace qu'un
projet de loi de finances ou les marges
de manoeuvre sont réduites à peu de
choses les sommes en question sont
pourtant considérables
la loi de programmation militaire
prévoit une dépense globale 295
milliards d'euros sur toute la période
le rapport de notre commission des
affaires étrangères indique que 198
milliards ont déjà été programmés il
resterait donc 95 milliards d'euros
engagés sur les deux dernières années
pour porter en 2000 25 à 50 milliards
d'euros le budget militaire de la france
déjà passé à 39 milliards d'euros cette
année alors qu'à peine ralenti la crise
du coc vide qu'à peine ralenti la crise
de covin votre gouvernement reprend déjà
le refrain de la maîtrise des dépenses
publiques contre les dépenses sociales
expliquez nous ce que vous allez
sacrifier pour parvenir à atteindre un
tel niveau de dépenses militaires vous
l'expliquer d'autant moins que selon
notre commission les surcoûts après à
prévoir atteignent déjà 8,6 milliards
d'euros ce qui aurait dû être une raison
supplémentaire d'avoir le débat sur le
périmètre d'actualisation il semble
d'ailleurs que l'amélioration de la
condition nos militaires les équipements
à hauteur d'homme pour nos soldats le
maintien en conditions opérationnelles
dont nous avions convenu la nécessité
lors de l'adoption de la loi de
programmation servent d'ores et déjà de
variable d'ajustement
le service de santé des armées reste lui
aussi en grande souffrance
le déficit en effectif pour les médecins
de premier recours s'est fortement
aggravée cette dernière année une loi
d'actualisation aurait permis plus de
transparence au lieu d'un blanc-seing
sans réel contrôle parlementaire
d'autant que la privatisation croissante
de zones de nos industries d'armement
affaibli le contrôle nécessaire de la
notion de la nation et fait s'envoler
les coûts les enjeux d'une loi de
programmation d'une telle ampleur ne
peuvent être examinés hors des concepts
stratégiques et l'entente servir depuis
2010 est le discours présidentiel n'a
cessé de renforcer l'affirmation selon
laquelle notre sécurité ne saurait être
assuré qu'avec un modèle d'armée complet
sur tout le spectre d'intervention de
plus en plus capables d'entrer en
premier dans des conflits de plus en
plus haute intensité
la montée des menaces justifierait donc
une armée de plus en plus tournés vers
la projection nos forces
or au moment même où vous
réaffirmer son modèle de projection
l'échec de l'opération barkan au sahel
sonne comme un rappel à l'ordre
nous y avons pourtant glottis
progressivement plus d'un milliard
d'euros par an notre assemblée qui a
moult fois sollicité auditions et des
bas pour questionner évaluer le bilan
réel de cette intervention militaire a
appris dans la presse le revirement
présidentielle sur marc khanne là encore
quel mépris du parlement
pour notre part nous n'avons cessé
d'alerter sur le risque d'engrenage de
la militarisation qui risquait de créer
un terrain propice à l'extension des
menaces jihadistes prospérant dans le
chaos créé par la guerre dans des pays
d'afrique toujours pillés et vulnérable
à la déstabilisation
malheureusement nous y sommes et les
violences s'étendent partout en afrique
au mali au burkina dans la région des
trois frontières au côte d'ivoire au
mozambique
il semble puisqu'il faut bien décrypter
ce qu'on refuse de venir nous expliquer
au parlement que la rationalisation
notre politique d'intervention militaire
en afrique soit moins un retrait de nos
armes et qu'une refonte une rencontre
figuration pour déployer plus encore nos
forces d'intervention dans plus de pays
le logiciel semble donc inchangés mais
les mêmes causes produiront les mêmes
effets pendant ce temps nous sommes
incapables comme le montre aura
probablement malheureusement le vote
définitif de la loi relative au
développement solidaire à la lutte
contre les inégalités mondiales de
programmer une véritable montée en
charge notre aide publique au
développement vers l'objectif de 0,7
pour cent de pipe
demain nous nous réunirons en commission
mixte paritaire sur cette loi de
programmation nous auront été incapables
d'inscrire un engagement ferme de 28
milliards d'euros à destination des pays
les plus pauvres d'ici 2025 28 milliards
dix fois moins que la lp m ces milliards
ne sont ils pas pourtant indispensables
à la sécurité du monde
notre priorité militaire est ce là
véritablement une politique de sécurité
planétaire
ne faudrait-il pas au contraire
travailler 2
nouvelle logique de développement et de
coopération qui fasse reculer le moins
disant fiscal et conforte la
mobilisation des ressources internes de
ces pays sans se donner les moyens d'une
hutte ambitieuse contre la pauvreté la
sous-alimentation les dérèglements
climatiques et toutes formes
d'insécurité du monde humaine dans le
monde
il y à fort à parier que la
militarisation croissante de nos
relations internationales ne provoque ni
paix ni sécurité collective ni recul des
formes de guerre hybrides ou
asymétriques
mais bien le contraire la dissémination
des violences et des conflits sans
parler des ventes d'armes nous sommes un
champion mondial qui disperse un peu
partout dans ce monde instable des
arsenaux qui sont de véritables bombes à
retardement comme on l'a vu récemment au
yémen oui tous nous incite à
réinterroger les objectifs de la lpm
nous prête en encre et la sécurité
mondiale en développant notre capacité
militaire de protéger de projection tous
les domaines nous le faisons en
revendiquant le concept de l'otan des 2%
des dépenses militaires dans les budgets
nationaux des pays de l'alliance
atlantique
nous courons sur tous les fronts de l'
escalade militaire dans les manoeuvres
militaires de l'otan en europe de l'est
face à la russie dans les démonstrations
de force maritime aux côtés des états
unis dans la zone indo pacifique face à
la chine en europe pour promouvoir de
couteau programme industriel de défense
aux objectifs stratégiques d'ailleurs
très mal définis en afrique
comme je l'aï dit nous apprêtons à
lancer le projet d'un porte-avions
nouvelle génération à propulsion est
clair estimé à 10 milliards d'euros
d'ici 2038
pour quels objectifs la sécurité de nos
espaces maritimes ou bien plutôt la
logique de puissance et la projection là
encore de nos forces extérieures
nous jouons le jeu dangereux de notre
puissance militaire comme d'une arme
politique et diplomatique
loin de nos besoins de sécurité
nationale nous acceptons sans broncher
la militarisation de l'espace
probablement l'un des plus grands
dangers est peut être l'un des plus
coûteux
du 21e siècle et nous lançons à nos
tours avec fierté un commandement
militaire de l'espace la lpm prévoit en
la matière d'importants investissements
pour tenter de rivaliser face au
programme massif étasunien ruche chinois
israéliens en la matière oui les traités
de 1967 et de 1979 on le sait doivent
être révisées pourtant en octobre 2018
notre gouvernement s'est montré
particulièrement discret quand il s'est
agi de discuter d'une telle révision
pour reprendre le jeu cite le communiqué
le nu des nations unies à l'époque sans
pour autant écouter l'a écarté la
possibilité d'un nouveau traité pour la
france le royaume-uni ou l'italie
l'urgence est toutefois d'adopter au
plus vite de nouvelles mesures qui
répondent aux préoccupations des plus
les plus aigus dit autrement on a
préféré mettre le doigt et même les deux
mains dans une machine dont on sait
qu'elle nous apprend le bras nous sommes
les acteurs d'une escalade militaire qui
est repartie mondialement sur un rythme
fou tout autant tirés par les appétits
de profits que font miroiter la
sophistication et les ruptures
technologiques que par les entrepreneurs
de violence et de guerre étatiques ou
non qui prospère dans les insécurités
mondiale où allons nous jusqu'à quand
pour préparer quelques qu'elle paie ou
plus exactement quelle guerre ce cycle
apparaît de nouveau sans fin plus tôt
que le fatalisme de la guerre et des
menaces
la froce tout en assurant sa sécurité
devrait lever à nouveau haut et fort le
drapeau de la désescalade
or nous ne sommes jamais au rendez-vous
des batailles mondial pour le
désarmement avant de mobilisation
s'élever aux nations unies pour relancer
un processus mondial de désarmement
militaire avec la signature par de
nombreux pays du traité d'interdiction
des armes nucléaires nous avons combattu
cette dynamique plutôt que de nourrir le
débat mondial et multilatérales en
faveur de nouvelles étapes de
désarmement nucléaire
la lpm aura consacré à son terme plus de
37 milliards d'euros à la modernisation
de trop dit
fazio or agir pour débarrasser le monde
et notre pays de ce fardeau dans un
processus multilatéral de désarmement
reste une condition de sécurité
collective et de paix vous l'aurez
compris notre groupe s'opposera au
quitus que vous nous demandez parce que
de tels engagements budgétaires ne
peuvent être ratifié à la légère encore
moins aujourd'hui qu'hier et parce que
nous avons plus que jamais besoin de
repenser les concept même de défense
nationale et de sécurité humaine global
planétaire autrement que par le seul
prisme de la progression de nos dépenses
militaires
pourquoi ne pas avoir prévu de voter sur
un projet de loi d'actualisation au lieu
de le faire sur un blanc signe politique
nos militaires que nos industriels
d'ailleurs n'attendent pas des
indications des engagements chiffrés
surtout de savoir que ceux ci seront
respectés comme ce fut le cas depuis
trois ans nous nous réjouissons de la
bonne exécution de la lpm mais
l'actualisation nous assurait c'est
l'avenir
l'incertitude de la courbe du pib que
vous avancé comme argument devrait au
contraire nous convaincre de sécuriser
la trajectoire budgétaire de la défense
pour les années 2000 24 2025
ce débat est un rendez vous raté notre
soutien était taxi à une véritable
discussion sur les ajustements apportés
en cours de programmation
nous souhaitions accompagné des
décisions parfois difficiles parce que
nous les comprenons et continuer tout
simplement à travailler en toute
confiance et dans la transparence sur
les enjeux majeurs de l'amélioration
opérationnelle et de la disponibilité
des équipements l'évolution des
effectifs et le respect de la
trajectoire financière sur le bilan au
tiers du parcours de la lpm les réponses
partielles du ministère des armées nous
ont confirmé ce que nous savions déjà à
savoir qu'il existe des besoins nouveaux
et que ceux ci devront être financés
enveloppe constante
certains grands projets financièrement
très lourds seront probablement
sanctuary zh et le renouvellement de la
dissuasion nucléaire le porte-avions de
nouvelle
les rations et le scaf nous le savons
depuis quelques heures
mais nous craignons des effets
d'éviction sur d'autres programmes
d'autant que l'apparition de nouvelles
menaces génère des besoins capacitaires
dans le domaine spatial et cyber ou
encore pour la lutte anti drones
s'agissant de l'armée de terre le
traitement des obsolescences du char
leclerc sera coûteux mais si l'on veut
être prêt pour la haute intensité
réaliser l'ambition 2030
cette remise à niveau devra se faire
sans effet d'éviction sur d'autres
aspects du programme scorpion
certes les évolutions de la
programmation sont naturels dans un
contexte stratégique fluctue re
s'agissant du programme industriel lourd
et technologiquement complexe mais ce
dont nous avons besoin monsieur le
premier ministre c'est de clarté sur les
programmes sanctuary zay et ceux pour
lesquels vous envisager un
ralentissement
quels seront les impacts de ces
arbitrages sur la mise en oeuvre des
objectifs de la lpm à l'horizon 2025
ce sont autant de raisons et de
questions pour lesquelles une revoyure
est essentielle afin de planifier
l'avenir et non simplement de revisiter
le passé que nous connaissons à
l'évidence si nous prenons en compte et
surtout des opex et les diverses
dépenses nouvelles de soutien et
d'imprévus nous dépassons mais cela est
déjà été rappelées les 8 milliards
d'euros
il s'agissait d'estimations mais elles
n'ont rien de fantaisiste
nous nous contentons de recenser des
ajustements qui sont indiscutables c'est
le gouvernement n'est pas d'accord avec
les chiffres
il lui appartient de mieux en informer
le parlement
enfin je voudrais mettre l'accent sur
l'un des objectifs majeurs de la loi de
programmation celui de prendre en compte
les besoins à hauteur d'hommes et de
femmes la question des programmes à
effets majeurs est indissociable d
autres opérations d'armement qui vise à
renforcer les équipements et la
protection individuelle de nos soldats
qu'il s'agisse de l'armement léger de la
vision nocturne ou des dispositifs de
lutte contre les engins explosifs
l'effort d'équipement promis au titre de
l'aide
ne doit pas être relâché concrètement un
suivi tout particulier doit être accordé
aux petits équipements qui occupe une
grande place dans la sécurité du
combattant et doivent à tout prix être
préservé le président de la république
pourrait dire quoi qu'il en coûte
alors nous apprenons une nouvelle
attaque à la voiture piégée au sahel
voudrais exprimer une pensée solidaire
pour nos blessés et leurs familles et
toute notre reconnaissance à celles et
ceux qui s'engagent jusqu'au sacrifice
de leur vie
face à la menace des mines et des engins
explosifs nous demandons l'accélération
de la livraison des kits de blindage
commandé en urgence afin de renforcer la
protection des véhicules blindés légers
comme l'a déjà rappelé mon collègue
cédric perrin il faudrait également
songé à ériger en priorité en priorité
nouvelle le projet de véhicules blindés
des dalles engagement le vb a eu pour
commencer à remplacer le vbl avant la
fin de la lpm nous constatons des
retards dans les livraisons du programme
scorpion
nous pouvons également nous interroger
sur notre autonomie en matière
d'approvisionnement de munitions notre
rapport d'information a mis en évidence
le besoin de chiffres est dès à présent
les besoins en matériel et en
préparation opérationnelle pour remplir
les objectifs de l'actualisation
stratégique et l'ambition 2030
il se chiffre en milliards d'euros la
question des effectifs de la
fidélisation et de l'amélioration de la
vie militaire n'est pas accessoire par
rapport aux équipements
c'est bien au contraire la valeur
cardinale de nos armes et celle sur
laquelle va reposer le lien de confiance
entre la nation et ses forces armées
je sais que nous en sommes tous
convaincus sur ses bancs et c'est
pourquoi il est dommage que nous ne
puissions offrir en retour aux femmes et
aux hommes qui nous protège et qui
mérite mieux qu'une simple déclaration
politique ou général une loi
d'actualisation qui sécurisent leurs
moyens et leur condition militaire
à cet égard au nom de mon groupe
politique je m'associe pleinement l
appel qui est lancé en faveur du service
de santé des armées
il est urgent de le doter des personnels
suffisants et d'offrir à nos médecins et
infirmiers de meilleures conditions de
vie à la hauteur de leur engagement pour
la nation pour toutes ces raisons qui
s'ajoutent à celles déjà
évoquée par mon collègue gilbert roger
le groupe socialistes écologistes et
républicains du sénat votera contre la
déclaration du gouvernement
je vous remercie au terme de débats quel
décalage monsieur le premier ministre
entre vos propos qui se résume à
l'autosatisfaction consigne avait aucune
ont donc un problème dans l'application
de la lpm décalage avec le bien fondé
des questions qui vous ont été posées et
pour lesquels nous attendons des
réponses
monsieur le premier ministre je me
permets de m'adresser à vous si vous
voulez bien m'écouter quelques instants
on ne peut pas en même temps dire qu'on
respecte le parlement et se flatter de
recourir systématiquement 53,1
comme si le parlement était une chambre
d'enregistrement sans possibilité
d'amendement car le cas normal d'un
débat entre le parlement et le
gouvernement
c'est bien la loi on ne peut pas en même
temps dire comme vous l'avez dit que
nous avons atteint les 2% et que pour
autant faut continuer l'effort gens nous
dire comment vous allez faire pour
continuer cet effort on ne peut pas en
même temps dire qu'on mette chien
les capacités opérationnelles et retirer
des rats salle sans dire quand ils vont
être remplacés comment et à quel coût
on ne peut pas en même temps dire que la
crise comme vous avez indiqué tout à
l'heure je reprends vos terme
bouleverser conditions de
l'actualisation de la lpm fut tiers-
connaître un bouleversement et ne pas
impliquer l'article 3 qui justement a
été écrit je le cite pour prendre en
compte l'évolution de la situation
macroéconomique on ne peut pas en même
temps dire qu'on respecte la lpm et
refusé d'appliquer de ses articles on ne
peut pas en même temps faire valoir le
quoi qu'il en coûte pour répondre à la
crise sanitaire et ne pas en tirer les
conséquences pour nos forces armées ce
premier ministre madame la ministre nul
tofu des lois fusse-t-il jupiter ce
n'est pas parce que le gouvernement
estime de façon unilatérale qu'il n'y a
pas lieu de légiférer que le parlement
souverain en la matière doit se ranger
sans discussion à cette appréciation
il n'y a pas de place pour lui en même
temps quand il s'agit de la souveraineté
de la france de nos armées de nos
soldats qui sont exposés il n'y a pas de
place pour le en même temps quand il
s'agit des prérogatives de souveraineté
de national vous demandé d'y renoncer
je ne peux imaginer un seul instant que
vous l'y ai plus pensé que nous étions
disposés à troquer pour solde de tout
compte
un texte de loi qui engage et vous et
nous contre un débat qui vous
dédouanerait de vos responsabilités et
réduire est le parlement à une simple
chambre d'enregistrement alors au terme
de ce débat finalement vous allez
peut-être avoir une satisfaction lorsque
nous allons passer au vote
parce qu'on a théorisé et de droite et
de gauche
eh bien je crains que dans le vote que
nous allons faire tout à l'heure vous
allez effectivement avoir cette
satisfaction sur les bancs et de droite
et de gauche nous risquons d'être
unanime je vous remercie
une elfe et m c'est une finalité
cette finalité c'est protéger les
français aujourd'hui et demain
cet lp m c'est l'outil indispensable ou
soutien de l'engagement politique du
président de la république en matière de
défense un plan de frappe de près de 300
milliards d'euros pour réparer et
préparer nos armes et la loi de
programmation militaire
c'est la réponse à une ambition celle
définie par le président la république
pour répondre aux enjeux d'un contexte
stratégique que certains d'entre vous
ont rappelé et qui est marqué par une
accentuation des tensions
internationales par la persistance de la
menace terroriste et par l'affirmation
désinhibé de puissance établie ou
émergentes et pas seulement dans les
milieux conventionnel mais aussi dans
les milieux hybride le cyberespace la
data ce faire ou bien espacé xu
atmosphérique
cette ambition comme l'a rappelé tout à
l'heure monsieur le premier ministre
c'est celle d'un modèle d'armée complet
qui dot nos forces militaires de moyens
d'action dans tous les milieux
terrestres maritimes aériens spatiale
les grands fonds marins
l'espace numérique bref tous les champs
d'opérations en toute autonomie et
autant que possible dans le cadre de
coopération
cette ambition je ne vous apprends rien
puisque vous en avez partagé l'analyse
puisque vous y avez pleinement adhéré et
la semaine dernière encore monsieur le
président vous me le rappeliez sans une
certaine fierté
ce 28 juin 2018
vous avez voté cette loi de
programmation militaire sans réserve à
326 voix contre 14 et par ce vote à une
très large majorité
vous avez exprimé votre plein soutien
aux orientations capacitaires et à la
trajectoire financière qui la sous-tend
parce que vous avez considéré que les
forces armées en avait besoin
parce que vous avez considéré que nos
forces méritait un effort national à la
hauteur de leur engagement
parce que tout simplement c'était
nécessaire
et comment en aurait-il était autrement
pendant des années le budget des armées
n'avaient cessé de diminuer
alors quand dans le même temps les
engagements de la france allait
croissant pendant des années la défense
avait été la variable d'ajustement des
finances publiques et cela fait quatre
ans que cela n'est plus le cas et je
m'en félicite
l'engagement de nos soldats aviateur et
marin est constant il est sans réserve
nous devons donc être à la hauteur dès
2017 et sans même attendre le vote de la
loi de programmation militaire
nous avons assuré la croissance du
budget des armées plus 1,8 milliard
d'euros en 2018 quand je dis nous c'est
nous tous et depuis ce sont 1 milliard
700 millions d'euros qui se sont ajoutés
chaque année la trajectoire financière
de cette loi de programmation militaire
se sont donc 27 milliards d'euros
supplémentaires cumulées qui ont été
injectés dans notre économie
c'est-à-dire qu'en quatre ans nous avons
apporté l'équivalent de deux années de
budget d'investissements supplémentaires
et je rappelle que sur la période 2010 9
2023 la lpm
c'est un total de 198 milliards d'euros
c'est à dire l'équivalent d'un plan de
relance un plan de relance destiné à la
défense
seuls ses considérables et c'est
essentiel pour notre économie au moment
même où après cette crise sanitaire sans
précédent
elle en a le plus besoin et quand je
parle de croissance du budget de la
défense
je ne parle pas de promesses je parle
d'acte car vous le savez mieux que
personne monsieur le rapporteur de la
commission des finances l'a rappelé
ils y allaient loi de finances initiale
mais il ya surtout l'exécution de ces
lois de finances et pour la première
fois depuis des décennies
la lpm est respectée chaque année les
crédits votés ont été conformes à la loi
de programmation militaire et chaque
année les ressources ont été infectées
et exécuté dans le respect de cette loi
de programmation militaire
j'en ai d'ailleurs rendu compte encore
tout récemment à l'assemblée nationale
au titre de l'année 2020 dans le cadre
du printemps de l'évaluation et je ne
doute pas que le président que j'aurai
encore en rendre compte
et c'est mon devoir devant votre
commission
cet effort historique s'inscrit dans la
durée monsieur le premier ministre vous
l'a rappelé il y à quelques instants
alors depuis le vote de la loi de
programmation militaire
nous avons fait du chemin et cela se
voit selon une formule que les
anglophones affectionne la lpm des
livres je ne détaillerai pas devant vous
la longue liste des matériels qui ont
d'ores et déjà été livrés à nos forces
les matériels arrive dans les unités et
nous constatons vous constatez chaque
jour l'impact positif que ce changement
opère sur le moral de nos militaires
quand on parle de loi de programmation
militaire
on a souvent tendance à se concentrer
sur les grands équipements
mais je voudrais vous dire qu'une lpm
c'est bien plus que cela
parce que
la guerre se gagne certes avec des
matériels mais la guerre se gagne
surtout avec des femmes et des hommes
qui sert notre pays avec courage et avec
abnégation
par conséquent la lpm 2019 2025 se
caractérise par sa hauteur d'homme et
quand on attend de nos forces qu'elles
s'engagent pleinement dans l'émission
que nous leur avons fixé quand on exige
d'elle le meilleur et bien nous devons
faire en sorte qu'elle puisse agir en
toute sérénité et nous devons pouvoir
leur donner des moyens à la hauteur de
leur engagement
j'ai donc c'est de cet axe une priorité
majeure de cette programmation militaire
et je suis fier de pouvoir vous dire que
les progrès sont là la liste est longue
alors je ne prendrait que quelques
exemples pour illustrer ses propos et je
sais que les membres de la commission
des affaires étrangères et de la défense
connaissent ces questions aussi bien que
moi vous savez qu'une attention
particulière a été apportée aux petits
équipements car ce sont les outils de
travail du quotidien près de cinquante
mille nouveaux fusils d'assaut ont été
distribués c'est plus de 60% de la cible
100 % des personnels qui sont déployés
en opérations extérieures sont équipés
du nouveau treillis ignifuges et plus
protecteur que le précédent
les nouveaux gilets pare balles ils ont
tous été livrés aux personnels qui
devait en être équipés certains d'entre
vous ont mentionné et je les en remercie
le plan famille il est extrêmement
complet et il a été mis en place pour
faire face aux difficultés qu'ils
étaient rencontrés par les militaires
leurs familles dans leur vie quotidienne
parce qu'il n'y a pas de soldats fort
sans famille heureuse
les mesures retenues couvre la condition
du personnel l'action sociale la
formation professionnelle l'emploi des
conjoints le logement l'hébergement
vous l'avez compris le cap est tenu il
est tenu face à des objectifs des
objectifs pardon que nous avions fixés
ensemble en 2018
alors je dois avouer ma perplexité
d'entendre que ceux qui en leur temps
avaient voté des coupes budgétaires
massives puisse dire qu'ils vont
s'abstenir voire voté contre
sans complexe sur une trajectoire qui
est en croissance et qui plus est
conforme à la loi qu'ils ont voté il y a
trois ans que faut-il comprendre qu'il
faudrait une diminution du budget de la
défense pour que leurs bottes soit
favorable
faut-il comprendre que les moyens qui
sont en hausse
ou bien que la modernisation de nos
armées qui sont permis parce tel pm
compte finalement beaucoup moins que
d'autres considérations qui probablement
ne sont pas des considérations de long
terme
alors mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs
la question que l'on peut se poser c'est
contre croix
allez vous voter contre l'amélioration
des conditions de vie de celles et ceux
qui risquent leur vie pour nous protéger
et je sais bien cela vous gêne
contre
entre une meilleure protection des
français aujourd'hui et demain contre le
renouvellement des blindés des frégates
et des avions vieillissants de nos
armées contre la mise en oeuvre à l'euro
près de la programmation que vous avez
approuvez vous le savez très bien s'il
existe un sujets régaliens qui eu égard
aux enjeux qu'il revêt pour notre nation
devrait dépasser les clivages politiques
c'est bien celui de la défense
je crois que les français méritent mieux
que sans que leur protection devienne
l'otage de querelles politiciennes
c'est inadmissible et c'est surtout
dangereux et qu'en penseront les
militants je vais je vais venir dans un
instant si vous le voulez bien sur cette
question mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs
je crois que nous vous avons écouté je
pense que nous pouvons aussi nous
exprimer dans le silence et qu'en
penseront les militaires eux-mêmes
car s'abstenir ou voter contre une loi
qui améliorent leurs conditions de vie
cela ne me semble pas être à la hauteur
de leur engagement
nous nous approchons du 14-juillet
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
alors la tâche on a nos armes et ne se
clame pas seulement ce jour là alors
j'en viens maintenant j'en viens
maintenant est là à la question que vous
posez c'est à dire pourquoi pourquoi il
n'ya pas j'y viens pourquoi agit bien
pourquoi il n'ya pas d'actualisation
l'objectif fixé par le président de la
république est claire
goulet rappelé atteindre 2% du pib à
l'horizon 2025 pour nos armées et si les
ressources financières ont été fixés sur
la première partie de la loi de
programmation militaire jusqu'en 2023
inclus pour vous souvenez sans doute
qu'il reste à définir l'exacte
trajectoire pour les deux dernières
années de la programmation 2024 et 2025
donc si l'on s'en tient à une lecture à
la lettre du texte de la loi de
programmation militaire
si l'on s'en tient comme vous le
préconisez à la lecture à la lettre de
son article 7 que se serait-il passé
nous l'aurions constaté cet objectif de
2% du pib
il est atteint il est atteint dès 2020
est ce que cela signifie que nous devons
arrêter nos efforts bien sûr que non il
faut les poursuivre et vous je n'ai
entendu personne me dire le contraire
est ce que nous devons considérer que
les forces étaient réparés que nous
devons nous en tenir là nous savons que
le chemin est encore long à parcourir et
que nous avons beaucoup à faire
alors si vous soutenez la défense comme
vous venez de le réaffirmer aujourd'hui
avec force
évidemment
qu'il faut soutenir cette loi de
programmation militaire c'est un choix
de cohérence et recourir
un texte législatif mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs utt inopérant
pourquoi parce que nous ne disposons pas
de prévisions macro économique fiable
pour les années 2000 24 et 2025
auriez vous souhaité prendre le risque
en quelque sorte de pénaliser nos armées
face à l'incertitude de la conjoncture
économique
alors pour autant pour autant mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs nous ne
restons pas statique on ne reste pas
l'armé au pied
selon l'expression consacrée un travail
important a donc été conduit en début
d'année sur l'actualisation stratégique
et j'ai eu l'occasion de vous en
présenter les conclusions en détail le
17 mars dernier
elle confirme toute la pertinence de
l'ambition fixée pour notre défense
toutefois elle souligne aussi que nous
n'avions pas anticipé nécessairement
l'accélération de certaines menaces et
de certaines tendances et donc des
inflexions sont nécessaires et elles
s'organisent autour de trois axes le
premier c'est mieux détecter et contrer
qui vise à renforcer la priorité que
nous donnons aux renseignements
en développant notamment nos capacités
défensives et offensives dans le champ
du cyber et du numérique
le deuxième intitulé mieux se protéger
consiste à accélérer l'effort qui est
porté sur la résilience c'est sur la
protection de nos forces et des français
sur le territoire national et il
concerne trois domaines en particulier
les risques nucléaires radiologiques
biologiques et chimiques dit nrbc la
santé et la lutte anti drone le
troisième s'intitule mieux se préparer
et il concerne l'entraînement et la
préparation opérationnelle les conflits
d'aujourd'hui montre que nos armées
doivent être prêtes à pouvoir riposter
dans tous les champs de la
conflictualité qu'ils soient matériels
ou immatériels cela demande donc un
entraînement plus conséquente et plus
sophistiquées et l'effort en cours sur
la disponibilité des matériels y
contribue directement
nous sommes donc bien en marche et nous
travaillons à ce que l'actualisation
puisse intervenir en temps utile alors
faute d'actualisation j'entends beaucoup
de choses des choses qui me semble
relever du mythe
à moins que ce ne soit un test pour les
capacités de lutte contre la
désinformation que nous développons au
sein de ce ministère est donc je
voudrais couper court à certaines
rumeurs
proulx a minima mauvaise interprétation
alors j'ai entendu les multiples
références dans vos interventions au
rapport d'information de la commission
des affaires étrangères et de la défense
du sénat
rapport qui à l'exception d'une synthèse
de quelques pages demeure introuvable
pour ceux qui le cherche
ce qui n'empêche pas certains néanmoins
de le saluer
en tout cas comme je n'ai pas eu la
chance d'en être destinataire vous
conviendrez qu'il m'est difficile d'y
répondre systématiquement point par
point mais je relève néanmoins que ce
qui figure dénote d'une vision centrée
sur un verre 5% vide plutôt qu'à 95%
plein et permettez moi de vous le redire
nous sommes au rendez vous et le verre
est bien à 95% plein alors ne parle de
surcoûts 8,6 milliards d'euros de
surcoût alors là je voudrais vous dire
tout de même de votre synthèse et des
plus ambiguës car même si elle n'est pas
longue il faut patienter jusqu'au milieu
de la cinquième page pour y lire entre
deux phrases en gras ces montants ne
représente en aucun cas un surcoût net
sur l' enveloppe de la lpm
nous voilà rassurés alors moi je vais
vous le dire de manière plus claire il
n'y a pas de surcoût de 8,6 milliards
la lpm je voulais 17 un plan de bataille
et à la guerre
on s'adapte la lpm n'est donc pas un
objet figé nous avons fixé un 4 sur une
longue période et nous l'exécutons en
nous adaptant à la réalité la réalité de
ce que nous appelons d'abord l'avis des
programmes
et puis la réalité qui est la
conjoncture économique
le fait que la crise sanitaire a créé un
certain nombre de problèmes à nos
industriels qui n'ont pas toujours été
en mesure de livrer à bonne date un
certain nombre d'équipements alors que
d'autres étaient en capacité de le faire
donc cet exercice il n'a rien de
théorique il se produit vous le savez
très bien tous les ans et il conduit à
des ajustements de trajectoire
capacitaire dont vous êtes informés à
travers les documents budgétaires les
rapports d'exécution que nous produisons
chaque semestre à votre attention
ils sont que ce rapport fasse référence
à certains décalages et ses décalages
c'est existe
j'y reviendrai dans un instant résulte
donné à lille d'une analyse détaillée et
d' une priorisation qui est totalement
assumée par les forces armées alors je
voudrais que évoqué nous relever plus
exactement un certain nombre d'erreurs
vous évoquez par exemple le surcoût du
programme
f2i et frégate d'intervention il n'y a
pas eu
il n'y a pas de surcoût nous avons
simplement décidé d'anticiper d'une
année la commande de la troisième
frégate commandes qui était prévu avant
la fin de la loi de programmation
militaire
où est le surcoût il s'agit d'une
décision qui permettent d'assurer la con
imiter du plan de charge de naval groupe
à lorient sur le sujet des dépenses du
coc vide
moi je me félicite de l'agilité dans le
mystère des armées a su faire preuve en
se mobilisant pleinement pour que tous
les crédits qu'ils ne pouvaient pas être
dépensés précisément en raison des
retards subis dans certains travaux
puissent être redéployés donc nous avons
accéléré la dépense partout où cela
était possible et ce n'est pas pour le
plaisir de dépenser l'argent public mais
bien pour répondre aux besoins de nos
armées et puis pour soutenir notre
économie au moment où elle en a le plus
besoin et c'est donc bien un milliard
d'euros qui a pu être injecté en plus
dans notre économie
il ne s'agit pas d'un surcoût mais de la
mise en oeuvre d'un système de vases
communicants entre les dépenses qui sont
anticipés et celles qui se sont
retrouvés retardé sur un autre registre
je voudrais relever des inquiétudes qui
ont été exprimées de façon récurrente
alors que nous enregistrons des succès
historiques à l'exportation concernant
le rafale je trouve tout de même
extraordinaire qu une excellente
nouvelle pour nos emplois pour nos
entreprises pour notre influence à
l'international soit considérée par
certains comme un problème alors
s'agissant de l'export du rafale à la
grèce vous savez que cette commande se
traduira par la production par dassault
de 18 avions neufs et j'ai déjà eu
l'occasion de le dire une cadence de
production d'un rafale par mois cela
représente
7000 emplois pas seulement chez dassault
mais aussi chez les 500 entreprises
petites et moyennes qui contribuent à la
chaîne de valeur du rafale et l'intérêt
n'est pas moindre lorsqu'il s'agit de
vendre des pins appareils d'occasion
en ce qui concerne donc cette
exportation vers la grèce je voudrais
rappeler que nous avons des gens passer
la commande qui permettra de compenser
l'impact de la cession d'appareils
d'occasion aux armées grecques pour
notre armée de l'air et de l'espace et
donc ces avions seront au rendez vous en
nous avons également eu un grand succès
en croatie puisque nous allons exporter
douze avions encore à la croatie
là aussi contrairement à ce que j'ai pu
entendre et je m'en suis entretenu
personnellement avec monsieur le
président de la commission ces appareils
seront évidemment compensée à l'armée de
l'air et de l'espace
alors ils ne partent pas immédiatement
et partent moins vite que les avions
grecs mais nous allons passer cette
commande donc où est le problème
où est le problème je les dis je le
répète donc je ne comprends pas mais je
vous le dit monsieur le président je
voulais dit je vous le répète
solennellement à cette tribune
donc quand vous le voyez il y a
finalement peu à redire sur cette loi de
programmation militaire et il me semble
et il me semble que c'est d'autant plus
difficile de trouver à y redire quand tu
tentes a manqué à nos armées sous les
mandatures précédentes
ça a été fort bien rappeler tout à
l'heure sur la période 2007 2015
le budget a été durablement maintenu
autour de 30 milliards d'euros ce qui ne
permettait même pas de maintenir le
pouvoir d'achat des armées entre 2010 et
2013 ce sont pas moins de 3 8 milliards
qui ont manqué à l'appel
lorsque l'on compare les budgets réalisé
à ce qui était prévu dans une aile pm
pourtant calculé au plus juste entre
2008 et 2015 160 mille emplois qui ont
été supprimés au ministère de la défense
et ces suppressions ont pesé sur toutes
les armées et tous les services de
soutien qui ont été particulièrement
mises à contribution
mettant en cause la capacité des armées
à conduire dans la durée des opérations
des réductions temporaires de capacités
majeurs avaient été consentis lors des
lois de programmation militaire
précédente patrouilleur de la marine
avions ravitailleurs et de transport la
loi de programmation militaire non
seulement pour voir à combler ces
réductions temporaires de capacité mais
elle s'emploie aussi à renouveler dvi d
équipements anciens dont le monde
maintien en condition opérationnelle
aurait été extrêmement coûteux alors je
m'étonne que l'on puisse s'offusquer du
décalage d'un an du lancement
réalisation du programme de la capacité
hydraulique au graphique du futur
lorsque notre marine a subi les
conséquences des coupes budgétaires les
périodes précédentes
je voudrais vous rappeler année
selon un rapport du sénat qui date de
2007 et qui disait déjà que le programme
fremm avait accumulé un retard de trois
ans et faut-il rappeler qu ensuite le
nombre de fremm qui étaient prévus dans
ce programme a été ramené de 17 à 8 mai
que le coût de ce programme lui n'a pas
varié
ce qui veut dire que la marine nationale
a acquis ces bateaux un coût unitaire
qui a été multiplié par deux alors le
sénat je le sais j'en suis témoin quand
il le veut c'est se distinguer par la
qualité de ses travaux
alors sur ce sujet on ne peut plus
sérieux celui de la programmation
militaire
s'il vous plaît retrouvez votre sérieux
et le sénat
[Musique]
le fener
le sénat quand il le veut
c'est prendre ses responsabilités et
vous l'avez prouvé en votant largement
cette loi de programmation militaire
vous l'avez prouvé en votant le budget
annuel qui en permettent l'exécution
alors ressaisissez vous
[Musique]
pour terminer mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs vous l'avez compris la lpm est
un engagement pleinement respectés par
le gouvernement nous ne devrions pas de
la cible le cap est fermement tenus et
cette loi de programmation militaire
vous le savez mieux que personne
c'est une première étape vers l'ambition
2030 vers le modèle d'armée complet
durable et équilibré qui permettra de
protéger la france et les français
des menaces futures cet effort de
remonter en puissance de nos armées nous
le poursuivrons évidemment au cours de
l'année 2021 et à travers le futur
budget 2022
pour cela il est essentiel que la
représentation nationale y apporte son
plein soutien
c'est un signal fort pour nos armées
comme pour les femmes et les hommes qui
les font vivre et qui vous écoutent et
qui apprécieront je vous remercie
merci à la ministre mes chers collègues
à la demande du gouvernement le sénat
est appelé à se prononcer par un vote
sur cette déclaration
conformément à l'article 39 alinéa 6 de
notre règlement ya donc et posséder un
scrutin public ordinaire dans les
conditions prévues par l'article 56 du
règlement et il n'y a pas d'explications
de vote
voici les résultats du scrutin 135
nombre de votants 344 nombre de
suffrages exprimés 282 pour l'adoption
46 contre 236
le sénat n'a pas adopté
[Musique]